bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est avec vous on est
en direct c'est figaro live et on attend
bien sûr vos points de vue faut-il
suivre l'exemple allemand
c'est les allemands ont franchi un cap
en interdisant carrément l'entrée sur
leur territoire de ressortissants
autrichiens ou tchèques afin de lutter
contre la propagation des variants du
courant navires us alors on en débat ce
soir avec nicolas baverez ce bonsoir
bonsoir alors économistes historiens
avocat et et surtout chroniqueur au
figaro
dernier ouvrage en date l'alertent
démocratique avec vous avec nous aussi
et bien alexandre ii avec lui au
journaliste au figaro bonsoir à nous
prendre en charge le figaro vox et
auteur de recomposition
le nouveau monde populiste c'est aux
éditions du cerf les populistes
précisément qui ont été vivement
attaquées par nicolas baverez
dans sa dernière chronique dans sa
chronique vous pouvez retrouver en ce
moment sur le site du figaro ils ont
fait la preuve de leur incompétence
alors le populisme at il échoué on en
débat avec vous avec vous messieurs
mais d'abord je vous recommande donc
comme chaque lundi la chronique de
nicolas baverez 16 mai avant j'aimerais
que vous répondez à la question faut-il
suivre l'exemple allemand berlin donc à
fermer les frontières avec l'autriche
pour stopper la propagation
du coronavirus en particulier en
provenance de la province du tyrol plus
gros foyers en europe du variant sud
africain est également fermeture des
frontières avec la république tchèque 10
% de la population a été ou est
contaminé par la cofidis 9 les régions
frontalières de l'allemagne ont une
forte proportion de variants anglais
alors berlin ferme berlin assume et à
bruxelles la commission européenne s'est
touche tout comme le secrétaire d'état
aux affaires européennes en france
clément bonne on fera tout en discussion
moi je ne souhaite pas que l'on ferme
que l'allemagne ferme complètement la
frontière doit tirer claire concertation
éviter une fermeture de frontières si
l'allemagne devait par l'application de
ces règles parce que l'instant le seuil
sanitaire et ce terrain restreindre
encore la circulation
je souhaiterais que l'on définisse
ensemble des exceptions les plus larges
possibles et nous avons évidemment deux
préoccupations majeures
le transport routier parce que ce sont
nos aliments nos médicaments notamment
qui de part et d'autres circulent
et puis bien sûr les travailleurs
frontaliers les travailleurs font
travail frontalier on va y revenir mais
d'abord nicolas question vous êtes du
côté de bruxelles ou du côté de berlin
dans cette affaire à vrai dire on doit
être un peu du côté des deux c'est à
dire que non mais pourquoi parce que ses
pruneaux mais pourquoi d'abord avec ce
virus surtout avec les variants qui sont
à la fois plus contagieux sans doute
plus dangereux
on voit bien que dans un certain nombre
de cas et notamment de deux régions
frontalières
c'est tout à fait rationnel de fermer
les frontières
là où on peut être du côté de bruxelles
c'est que c'est un problème depuis le
début de cette épidémie
c'est que le fait que chacun fasse pays
par pays c'est quand même complètement
absurde
autrement dit qu'on n'ait pas été
capable de mettre en place un protocole
pour le transport aérien avec les mêmes
règles dans tous les aéroports de
schengen évidemment qu'il faut contrôler
les aéroports les ports les frontières
mais que depuis le début on soit
incapable dans cet espace qui est censé
être un espace commun de se mettre
d'accord sur les mêmes règles c'est
quand même
tu as fait c'est quand même tout à fait
dommage est la dernière chose ou
également on peut être du côté des
allemands c'est que j'allais dire que
pour le coup annonce la fermeture des
frontières mais surveille vraiment c'est
à dire qu' il n'y a pratiquement plus de
train qu'on a mis des gens qui sur le
cas français reste un cas aberrant
puisque on a annoncé à de multiples
reprises soit la fermeture des
frontières soient des contrô les
aéroports tous les gens qui sont passés
dans les aéroports etc savent qu'en
réalité il ya aucun contrôle et donc en
dehors de quelques vols qui viennent de
très loin les gens qui arrivent ne sont
pas contrôlés il n'y a pas de contrôle
il n'y a pas de tests et est donc c'est
ça qui reste assez curieux dans le cas
français c'est que on n'arrête pas de
faire des annonces
et ça n'est pas suivie de réalités
opérationnelles dans lequel l'allemagne
s'est suivie de et ensuite ce qui a été
dit par le ministre est exact c'est à
dire que derrière pour un pays comme la
france est particulièrement important
parce que chez nous il faut jamais
oublier que les choses se sont inversées
c'est à dire qu'il ya quelques décennies
les gens venaient plutôt travailler en
france aujourd'hui c'est complètement la
mer c'est à dire que on a des centaines
de milliers de français qui tous les
jours vont travailler au luxembourg en
allemagne et en suisse et donc pour tout
cela c'est vital de pouvoir pour la vie
de leurs familles ont varié au pouvoir
alors travailler on va y revenir
justement aller qui sont par rapport à
ce que vient de dire nicolas est ce que
vous êtes d'accord
vous êtes duc ce que vous êtes vous même
du côté un peu de bruxelles un peu de
berlin mais j'ai toujours estimé que
berlin et bruxelles c'était un peu la
même chose donc
première chose on a la démonstration que
quand l'allemagne veut faire quelque
chose elle le fait ça reste un pays
souverain parce qu'ils ont une économie
forte parce que c'est sûr qu'ils ont eux
su se redresser et panneaux et donc
c'est eux qui imposent
le tempo donc c'est pas c'est pas
nouveau
pensé comme paul marie coûteaux dans
l'europe vers la guerre quand la france
construit l'europe l'allemagne construit
l'allemagne pourtant ils font la même
chose c'est à peu près ça et là deuxième
confirmation qu'on attend c'est très
c'est que schengen est mort de la même
manière que maastricht a été quand même
très largement suspendue et sans doute
durablement on voit bien que l'europe
telle qu'elle existait ne fonctionne pas
y compris l'europe de schengen puisque
les allemands ont bien compris que nous
n'étions pas capables de faire respecter
les mêlées propres mesures comprend de
contrôle des frontières et donc sont
obligés aussi il faut leur reconnaître
et de prendre des mesures unilatérales
de colas les interrompt les stands mais
avec sans rien dire schengen est mort
est ce que c'est votre votre avis où
vous pensez simplement que c'est juste
un accident de l'histoire ce qui vient
de sa je crois va pas c'est pas un
accident de l'histoire au sens où la
comparaison avec maastricht et fondé
c'est à dire que maastricht et l euro
avec des règles dont on savait qu'elle
était insoutenable
il ya eu la crise est derrière et le
reste on est de 3% du déficit
oui mais surtout il y avait l'idée qu'il
y avait une convergence automatique
alors qu'on a une et surtout l'idée qu'
il n'y aurait pas de chocs internes ou
externes donc il n'y avait pas de
capacité à gérer les crises et les
crises évidemment on en a eues schengen
c'est un peu la même chose on a mis en
place un système de libre circulation
sans aucun contrôle
bon évidemment il faut si on n'a pas de
contrôle à l'intérieur il faut avoir des
contrôles à l'extérieur et la crise des
migrants avaient commencé à montrer le
problème donc moi je crois que schengen
survivra mais que ce qui s'est passé là
va amener
à changer à changer les règles et
notamment je pense qu'on va avoir un
vrai contrôle aux frontières
on commence à le voir avec frontex telle
reste regardez ce qui s'est passé c'est
quand même très intéressant avec la
turquie et la tentative d agde erdogan
au printemps dernier d'envoyer un flux
massif de migrants vers l'europe
maintenant il ya un mur et les européens
ont aidé les grecs à tenir la frontière
et les dizaines de milliers de gens qui
avaient été envoyés par erdogan ne sont
pas rentrés en 2015 il serait rentré
sans aucune difficulté donc je pense que
schengen survivra mais de là où c'est en
partie vrai c'est que schengen ne
survivra pas comme il a été créé sur
guesnes ne survivra pas comme il a été
créé c'est votre point de vue oui alors
le le scénario qui est peut-être idéal
et qui est peut-être le le scénario pour
une europe puissante maître de ses
frontières c'est qui est double
frontières a finalement un schengen ont
renforcé pourquoi pas dans des cas comme
le cas grec effectivement c'est un bon
cas où il fallait l'appui de l'europe
pour quoi aider les grecs
et puis ils nous font une des frontières
internes qu on voit réapparaître cette
liberté des frontières internes qu
est-ce qui va du traité de schengen est
justement l'ouverture des frontières à
l'intérieur d'un site et d'un espace je
pense effectivement que la philosophie
de l'europe sans frontières est balayé
et c'est plutôt heureux maintenant si
l'europe arrive à se ressaisir et à
avoir des fonds dia externe protectrice
et une souplesse des états qui sont
capables de jouer avec leurs frontières
alors contrôler les de les contrôler ce
sera une évolution positive de l'autre
mais c'est sera déposé une une évolution
qui se fait là son la commission sans
les technocrates de bruxelles sont
emmanuel macron qui lui est dans un
autre le logiciel d'une vieille europe
pour voir qu'il ya un combat à
l'intérieur de l'europe entre ceux qui
sont réalistes et ce qu'ils veulent pour
continuer ce même projet qui est un
projet des années 80 sur mondialisation
heureuse fantasque un jeu vendu par
rapport à ce que disait
nicolas tout à l'heure c'est une
question je voulais vous poser alexandre
donc là l'allemagne donc ferme les
frontières avec l'autriche et la
république tchèque le bade wurtemberg un
land frontaliers de la lorraine demande
la fermeture de la frontière avec la
moselle qui est justement un foyer
également du variant sud africain ce que
vous approuvez
j'ai bu je peux qu'on me mettre à la
place je pense que si j'étais allemand
je ferais la même chose
oui mais je pense que là il y avait hier
il ya un problème épidémique que c'est
même là dans l'intérêt de tout le monde
que le virus ne se propage pas partout
en europe
chaque pays avait européens avaient fait
comme ça peut-être le virus aurait mois
circuler à l'intérieur de l'europe donc
ça ne ça ne me choque pas ce qui me
choque c'est que effectivement on
devrait appliquer la réciproque on devra
revoir un gouvernement français qui au
lieu d'expliquer on va se concerter
c'est pas bien et sait prendre les
mesures et se donne les moyens
d'appliquer ses propres mesures puisque
on a dit qu'on contrôlait au moins les
gens qui revenaient à l'extérieur de
schengen est effectivement dans les
aéroports on peut constater que ce n'est
pas fait
nicolas ce que je voulais rappeler quand
même d'un mot c'est que par ailleurs si
on raisonne un peu sur le long terme
s'il ya un pays en europe qui a intérêt
à avoir des frontières ouvertes c'est
bien la france puisque je rappelle que
malheureusement on a réduit notre
industrie à 10% du pib' la france elle
vit de service c'est la première
destination touristique du monde
donc s'il ya un pays qui a intérêt est
par ailleurs les touristes à forte
valeur ajoutée ces touristes étrangers
donc si on veut faire repartir notre
hôtellerie notre restauration notre
secteur culturel tout l'événementiel
les foires les expositions et tout ce
genre de truc très franchement la france
elle a un intérêt vital à ce que ça se
trouvera et évidemment pour que ça se
trouvera il faut que ça se trouve dans
des conditions sanitaires qui soit
sécurisée d'où l'importance des vaccins
d'où l'importance du passeport vaccinale
etc mais vous aussi vous voulez il faut
je pense qu'en ce moment il n'y a pas
tellement le choix avec ces variants
mais ce qui est très important parce
qu'une fois de plus on agit sous la
contrainte
on agit en dernière minute et ils ont
réagi puisque on agit mais si vous
voulez sur le moyen terme et si on veut
pensée stratégique
l'important et c'est peu c'est ce qui
est intéressant avec ce qui s'est passé
avec ce refus d'un nouveau confinement
c'est que maintenant il faudrait que les
pouvoirs publics arrêtent de rester
bloqué dans cette idée que il faut tout
arrêter il faut ficher que ce qui est
important c'est que les gens restent
chez eux etc
il faut passer à un autre logiciel qui
et comment est ce qu'on fait pour
rouvrir comment est ce qu'on fait pour
ce que l'activité économique et la vie
sociale puissent reprendre
même en mode dégradé et de manière et de
manière sûre et c'est parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on va faire repartir notre
pays et il ya une vraie course de
vitesse puisque cela dit elle l'asie
elle elle marche parce que regarder même
aujourd'hui
ou est ce que vous voulez ou est ce que
vont les gens m'attendent et services it
services
ils vont en italie ou en espagne parce
que en italie vous avez des bars des
restaurants des musées et que en espagne
c'est la même chose je suis d'accord sur
la nécessité de élan repartir d'ouvrir
des restaurants etc sont les services de
nombreux mots sur les services alors sur
le service wiiware les frontières c'est
un choix a été fait des élites
effectivement 2
désindustrialisé massivement la france
je pense que rétablir un peu de
protectionnisme et avoir un projet à
long terme on peut articuler le court le
moyen et le long termes de
réindustrialisation ça serait pas mal on
a vu avec cette crise que de compter
uniquement sur les services et aux
touristes
ça nous affaiblisse est grandement
ensuite soit les frontières il faut pas
être binaire
quand on parle de rétablir des contrôles
aux frontières et jamais était pas
question de nous barricader et
d'empêcher les pourrissent devenir
simplement de contrôler pour la question
migratoire
pour ce qui est des échanges peut-être
faire un peu de protectionnisme
justement pour retrouver à terme une
industrie et donc donc ne faisons pas
croire qu'on défend des murs tout autour
de la france mais simplement en avoir la
maîtrise être capable en cas de crise
pendant pandémique comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et éventuellement de les
fermer les ouvrir les contrôler tout
simplement s'appeler d'un mot avant
coûts non mais je ne le pouvais mais le
protectionnisme
cc c'est la pire manière de
réindustrialiser il faut être clair le
marché français ces 60 millions
d'habitants
donc il n'ya pas une industrie dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui qu'ils puissent
vivre avec un marché de 67 millions donc
regardons pourquoi est-ce que des petits
pays prenons pourquoi est ce qu'israël
arrive à avoir par exemple une industrie
de défense une industrie du cyber qui
tient la route
parce que il se trouve qu'il sera bel
arrive à se projeter
même en étant un petit pays dans un
environnement très protectionniste ça
veut pas dire qu'on vit en
autosuffisance personne n'a dit fox et l
autarcie essaie simplement de se
protéger contre les produits à bas coût
sur ses terres à l'industrie il faut
être compétitif c'est très il faut
baisser les impôts il faut investir dans
les secteurs stratégiques
mais ce sera difficile de reconstruire
une industrie et si on est envahi par
des produits à bas coûts face auxquels
on sera jamais compétitif puisque parce
qu'on par nature à part de transformer
les salariés français en chinois
on n'y arrivera pas juste une autre une
autre question puisque en parler de
l'accord
la coordination européenne ou de
l'absence de coordination européenne
il y a eu quelques jours la signature
d'un accord bilatéral entre israël et la
grèce
en d'autres termes moyennant un
passeport vaccinale est bien les grecs
pourront les faire du tourisme en israël
il israéliens pourront les faire du
tourisme en grèce tout ça ça s'est passé
sans bruxelles
est-ce que vous approuvez ça mais si
vous voulez à partir du moment où on est
rentrés effectivement dans un monde où
il ya plus de coordination ce qui est
certain c'est que là où il faut
réfléchir c'est que comme souvent les
israéliens sont assez novateur et
innovant et en tout cas je pense que ça
montre la manière dont on pourra faire
repartir le tourisme et donc au lieu de
se battre contre le passeport vaccinale
les autorités françaises devraient
commencer à regarder quel est l'intérêt
parce que notamment sur le terrain
tourisme haut de gamme qui est un
tourisme de gens qui veulent la sécurité
si on n'est pas capable d'assurer de la
sécurité il y aura pas de tourisme haut
de gamme en france et donc c'est aussi
ça que ça veut dire donc c'est
certainement pas l'idéal moi j'aurais
bien ce qui est très dommage c'est que
effectivement ça paraît très plus
logique et plus naturelle qu'on ait fait
ça d'abord à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne avant qu'on le fasse avec
avec israël simplement quand le système
européen n'est pas réactif et ben j'en
reviens ben oui donc vous voyez vous
rigoler avec sa mère phase c'est-à-dire
que vous approuvez l'idée comme le
nicolas d'un passeport avec cynthia j'ai
fait dit que je l'approuvé de manière
générale mais c'est un accord bilatéral
passé entre les grecs et les israéliens
je le respecte ce qu'il a mais quand on
a la démonstration tous les jours dans
cette crise que la coordination les
normes etc européenne ne fonctionne pas
et donc on revient aux bilatérales il
aurait peut-être été plus simple de
commencer par là ont facilité tout
l'idée d'un passeport vaccinale de
manière générale et dans ces cas là
écoutez moi je pense que pour parler de
passeports vaccinale en france il faudra
commencer par avoir un vaccin
on n'a pas été capables de le produire
on n'est pas capable de le déployer
ça me paraît très bizarre aujourd'hui
d'imposer aux gens
un passeport vaccinale alors qu'ils ne
peuvent pas se faire vacciner
juste une dernière pièce alors il ya
plein de
d'internet de remarques d'internautes je
voulais donner il y avait également
ce commentaire sur twitter justement par
rapport à la question qu'on pose c'est
faut-il donc suivre l'exemple allemand
et fermé les frontières
c'est la question qu'on pose sur sur
twitter et romain ne disait notamment
l'idée que la france puisse entrer entre
guillemets en guerre économique et
politique contre l'allemagne n'a
toujours pas à pleurer
nous ne sommes pas un couple mais des
adversaires parfois des alliés de
circonstance
je crois que on est sûrement plus un
couple au sens où les pays ont trop
diverger or ce qui était ni sur
l'économie c'est vrai que maintenant
c'est absolument accablant c'est à dire
que on a d'un côté une france là qui va
perdre 9 % de son pib qui a un taux de
chômage qui va monter vers 12 13 % qui à
120% du pipe de dette publique qui a
pratiquement une industrie une recherche
extrêmement diminué de l'autre côté on a
une allemagne qui ne va perdre que 5%
qui va retrouver très vite dès l'année
prochaine son niveau de richesse qui a
75 % de dette publique qui est en plein
emploi qui montrent qu'elle a une
industrie une recherche rigoureuse
donc ensuite la france garde des atouts
notamment au plan militaire au plan
stratégique que l'allemagne n'a pas mais
c'est vrai que dans dans le monde
européen qui pour l'instant est un monde
qui est mû par ledroit le marché le
commerce
aujourd'hui il ya plus de couples
simplement parce que les les poids des
deux pays sont très différents dont
l'allemagne est clairement aujourd'hui
le seul leader de l'union européenne la
france est le premier des pays du sud
c'est la triste réalité et commentaires
d'alexandre parce que le temps file
on a peut-être un désaccord si on veut
faire un couple franco allemand dans ces
conditions là ça veut dire qu'on est ce
quart à quasiment sous tutelle de
l'allemagne moi je crois pas que ce soit
le la solution ça posera trop de deux
problèmes démocratiques quand bien même
il y aurait des réformes ou des efforts
de reconstruction reconstruction à faire
de côté français à mon avis elle et ça
doit être fait avec l'accord des
populations sous l'impulsion de dd
propre gouvernement français et
peut-être malgré tout différemment que
ce qu'on a fait en allemagne parce que
le l'histoire la société française est
différente de l'histoire et de la
société allemande tout simplement je
vous propose un jour de revenir pour
parler du couple franco allemand parce
que ça vaut je pense un débat en soi
peut-être une émission en soit je donne
la parole aux internautes les frontières
aurait dû être contrôlée depuis le début
de cette épidémie est deux fois plus dès
l'apparition des variants nous y
chardons bleus
elle nous dit à vrai dire je croyais que
nos frontières étaient déjà fermés
nicole 06 encore sur le figaro.fr je
remarque que l'allemagne qui impose
toujours l'europe se permet de commander
des vaccins sol de son côté fermé des
frontières dans son coin gaz sur youtube
nous dit mieux vaut tard que jamais il
faut moins imposer le test négatif mais
de moins de 24 heures c'est le minimum
rené lui s'interroge est ce que cela est
efficace il faut éviter de reproduire
systématiquement toutes les mesures non
prouvées mise en place par les autres
pays et lights pire encore sur youtube
laisser les frontières ouvertes cet
exposé les pays du moins touché au
niveau de contamination des plus
touchées c'est logique de vouloir
contrôler son pays en fermant la porte
alors c'est la question qu'on posait sur
twitter je donne encore à juste avant de
vous donner la réponse
le commentaire de nathan 770 s'il paraît
stupide de refuser des touristes venant
des pays menant des bonnes politiques
sanitaires au moins aussi bonne que la
nôtre et micheline
elle estime en revanche que fermer les
frontières n'est pas très utile car le
virus circulera toujours le virus ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières est bien la
question qui est posée sur twitter était
faut-il suivre l'exemple allemand est
fermé
les frontières et pour l'instant je suis
désolé micheline c'est plutôt le oui qui
l'emportent à 77%
il y à une autre question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter je voulais donner dans
un instant mais je vous recommande
auparavant comme chaque lundi la
chronique de nicolas baverez
alors elle est un peu sombre ce lundi
très tôt ghislaine normal vous venez
d'écrire un livre sur sur tocqueville
qu'on recommande encore le monde selon
tocqueville c'est bien ça et les
dirigeants
vous pourrez y lire en tous les cas dans
non pas dans le monde selon toby mais
dans la chronique de nicolas que les
dirigeants populistes ont fait la
démonstration de leur irresponsabilité
et de leur incompétence le populisme a
échoué nicolas vous pensez à la hongrie
par exemple
non mais si on reprend le ce qui s'est
passé à cette vague populiste
elle a donc démarré en 2016 avec le
break site l'élection de donald trump et
elle s'est étendue sur tous les
continents y compris dans le monde
émergent avec par exemple à airbus au
now au brésil et puis est arrivé
l'épidémie et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est vrai quand on regarde
ball sonar ou trump ou boris johnson
sûre en tout cas avant la phase
vaccin ils ont été dans le déni
ils sont passés complètement à côté et
sur le plan sanitaire économique quand
on regarde aujourd'hui l'état du royaume
uni sur le plan économique ça reste très
compliqué mais ce qu'il faut bien
mesurer c'est que la crise de la
démocratie c'est ce que dit l'article
l'arc la crise de la démocratie elle
reste devant nous on voit que la
démocratie est sûre le recul un peu
partout et le le fait que les populistes
et mal gérer l'épidémie
ça ne règle pas le problème pour la
noyer des causes profondes de cette
profonde choc populiste c'est à dire la
déstabilisation des classes moyennes par
la mondialisation l'atomisation des
sociétés par les réseaux sociaux le
sentiment juste que l'occident est en
train de perdre la partie et que le
monde bascule vers l'asie et notamment
vers la chine
plus les problèmes identitaires et
culturelles avec la web culture et cette
machine à fragmenter les les sociétés
donc tout ça ça reste en revanche devant
nous et donc le le populisme comme
réaction à ces problèmes l'âge l'échec
des populistes ne fait pas disparaître
ces problèmes de fond qui sont ceux que
la démocratie doit régler pour avoir un
abri au 21e siècle c'est très clair il
faut s'y mettre c'est très clair il ya
deux choses dans ce que dit nicolas
alexandre d'abord vous allez répondre à
la première première idée de nicolas
c'est que les populistes ont échoué dans
la gestion du jeu comme un navire ça
tombe bien vu dans la deuxième vidéo on
fait le même gardant le même diagnostic
le
le noise peu de temps donc justement la
première le brésil et les états unis
c'est vrai huîtres up avant que ne
survienne le vaccin ça allait pas très
fort alors moi j'ai toujours mis le
brésil un peu de côté je considère être
que bolt ball sauna ou est un libéral
autoritaire pas pas si loin d'eux
d'autres libérale autoritaire qu'on
connaît dans ces scènes plaisanterie
c'est surtout un pays d'amérique latine
avec des problématiques totalement
différentes des nôtres les pays
d'amérique d'amérique latine à mon avis
non jaloux d'amérique du sud n'ont
jamais vraiment totalement connu la
démocratie donc je mets un peu bull soit
ils n'ont jamais eu de vraie classe
moyenne même si elles étaient émergentes
au brésil dont je met ball sonar aux
deux côtés sur les états unis alors
donald trump a perdu l'élection
donc ça c'est un échec politique double
échec politique puisque je pense que
l'attak du du capitole totalement mis
une tache sur un bilan qui effectivement
n'était peut-être pas si mauvais que ça
en termes de pure politique dans la
gestion de la crise dure en avant en
termes de pure politique il a ramené de
10 millions de voix dans plus à son
parti ce qui n'est ce qui n'est pas rien
il avait un bilan économique qui était
excellent avant la crise du coronavirus
et les états unis vont repartir beaucoup
plus vite que nous et sur la crise du
coronavirus gestion erratique mais je
nuancerais parce qu'en forte proportion
du nombre d'habitants le nombre de morts
est un peu près le même que celui de la
france
et eux ils ont été en capacité de
produire un vaccin est apparemment de le
distribuer beaucoup plus vite que nous
donc le de même pour pour le royaume uni
ou bob johnson s'est planté dans un
premier temps sur la stratégie de
l'immunité collective mais semble pour
le moment se rattraper sur le bassin à
le vaccin et l'angleterre qui semblent
plus rapides plus souple d'ailleurs que
l'union européenne nous aurait expliqué
que le break site était une catastrophe
donc je nuancerais on ne peut pas dire
non plus par exemple que la gestion
française de la crise ait été excellente
je crois qu'un ecolab havraise ne
retrouvera là dessus ni de toutes les
démocraties libérales ya des nuances
vous avez d'ailleurs cité l'exemple de
viktor orban
tout à l'heure vous avez commencé par là
nicolas baverez zap a répondu j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit spécialement
mal gérée hongrie et ensuite il ya les
régimes moi que je considère comme
autoritaire pour la russie voire
totalitaire pour la chine que vous vous
cassiez plutôt dans les régimes
populistes ou et qui ont été
relativement efficace voire très
efficace aussi et donc le le tableau est
plus nuancé que ce que dit nicolas
baverez d'après j'ai jamais pensé que le
populisme est elle associée celui ci a
tout comme base je pense que c'est un
symptôme mais je pense aussi que si on
compare entre les populismes et les
technocrates
voilà qui dirige en france depuis des
années et qui dirige l'union européenne
et bien la comparaison entre les deux et
pas forcément des avantages des
populistes alors je fais juste une
précision de jeu posé la question à
nicolas mais comme je vous pose la
question à vous donc à chaque fois que
je fais l'avocat du diable
nous ne sommes nous a pas échappé et une
question qui est posée
justement peut-être pourrait rebondir
par rapport à ce que dit alexandre cet
internaute sur twitter qui nous lie en
quoi les souverainistes
alors vous parlez vous des populistes 1
donc c'est on va faire peut-être
sont-ils des irresponsables il faut il
faut que les vandelli cesse de
considérer ceux qui ne pensent pas comme
eux comme des crétins et ça vous ne le
pensez pas que sont des crétins mais par
contre effectivement sur cette histoire
mais deux des technocrates e repense pas
qu'on puisse assimiler des gens qui
croient à la souveraineté
des populistes comme cela ce n'est pas
que poutine et populiste m'a pas semblé
non alors justement je pense que le si
vous voulez dans les dents les problèmes
de la démocratie donc il ya les
adversaires extérieurs des adversaires
extérieurs il ya les démocrates eurent
et les djihadistes les démocrates eurent
c'est la chine la russie la turquie et
puis il ya un régime très particulier
qu'est la théocratie iranienne
ensuite les populistes sont des donc des
mouvements qui sont dirigés par des
leaders charismatiques et qui joue sur
les passions collectives des passions
nationalistes protectionniste ou
xénophobes parfois mais si vous voulez
là où la chose est très différente c'est
que c'est pas des adversaires extérieurs
de la démocratie ce sont des forces
intérieures à la démocratie et qui
appelle à son déplacement comme on l'a
connu un peu dans l'est dans les années
30 mais avec avec d'autres formes
donc c'est pour ça que et je pense pas
du tout que 20
poutine noir de gamme c'est pas des
populistes c'est cette sonde et ce sont
des régimes qui sont différents ce qui
me paraît si on veut juste oui en deux
minutes
évidemment c'est pas pour dire que la
france a bien géré la crise
ce que je trouve ça intéressant quand
même une minute parce que c'est très
sous-estimées souvent chez nous c'est de
regarder quand même mondialement c'est à
dire que ce qui est intéressant quand
même c'est que quand on regarde de ceux
qui ont vraiment bien géré la crise
sanitaire et économique
ce sont des démocraties mais ce sont des
démocraties que généralement chez nous
on sous-estimé on regarde très peu
c'est à dire la nouvelle-zélande la
corée du sud taïwan donc japon le sait
quand même délit qui on défend pas moins
qu'ils ont des caractéristiques que vous
pourriez qualifier délibérera oui on a
parlé en valeur du protectionnisme
indien - la corée du serial bon
certains pays d'europe du nord la suisse
s'en sort pas si mal
et puis israël il ya bien tenu et qui
sur la l est qui est le leader quand
même sur les lieux des relations plutôt
souverainiste plus tôt il aimait hall
plutôt protection je ne pense pas du
tout qu'on puisse dire que la nouvelle
zélande et libérale c'est vrai que c'est
une idée je ne connais pas le sait mais
je pensais la corée au japon la suisse
mais je pense que sur la grèce a fait
parler d'un réveil de ged dire que la
corée ou taïwan sont des régimes
libéraux
c'est absolument faux outre la hongrie
oui mais ce n'est pas du tout le pas du
tout la corée du sud ou ou taïwan
ce sont des vraies démocraties je
rappelle même que la corée du sud a
réussi à organiser des élections qui ont
été parfaitement régulière en avril
dernier 0 personne ne parle des
élections et régulière de même que les
ondes et aux états bien sûr pas
irrégulière il ya un vrai que rallye
c'est un vrai état de droit il ya un
vrai système de calendrier libéral ou
pas libéré la balle alors il est
totalement ici libéral oui elle le dit
elle-même assez vite devant eux mêmes
qui sont rien moi j'ai tendance à
écouter les gens bel été de même que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi la vème
république à la base et un régime
libéral vouloir indiquant dans la très
bonne interview du figaro qu'on a fait
mais démocratique et compte bien sûr
comme la chronique de nicolas
juste une dernière question même si
marie amélie me répète dans l'oreille
que s'est terminée juste une question
est ce que quand même la réussite de ces
démocraties que vous avez cités u sud
est asiatique
ça vient pas ils n'ont pas un point
commun c'est leur insularité ce sont
souvent des îles ou des presqu'îles
notamment la corée et donc ça ça
empêcher quand même un certain nombre d'
échanges entre les cas c'est une thèse
qu'on a qu'on a pu on a pu entendre
et puis notamment aussi si les pays qui
avaient connu
le h1n1 et qui avait pu tirer des
conséquences et en particulier des
conséquences sanitaires de cette
épidémie
alors d'abord évidemment le facteur
insulaire ça joue par exemple pour la
nouvelle-zélande
évidemment h1n1 ça a laissé des traces
extrêmement forte pour des pays comme
taiwan ou la corée du sud qui était à
proximité immédiate et je crois qu'il ya
des facteurs plus important et qui sont
intéressants parce que les démocraties
occidentales devraient s'en servir pour
réfléchir à l'avenir
on a deux dans des états qui sont
puissants forts qui ont su anticiper qui
ont réagi très vite on a une très bonne
cohésion sociale très forte cohésion
nationale et on a aussi une population
qui est très éduquée est notamment très
éduqués aux nouvelles technologies il ya
un usage libérale des nouvelles
technologies conforme à l'état de droit
dans ces pays donc vous voyez c'est un
ensemble et ça je trouve que c'est
intéressant parce que ça c'est des
points sur lesquels on a vu que les
démocraties occidentales avaient
beaucoup perdu
il y même quand l'état est énorme comme
en france il marche plus il ya plus de
cohésion nationale il ya un vrai
problème d'unité nationale est par
ailleurs en matière de nouvelles
technologies
on a mesuré leur teint et même sur des
secteurs comme la santé ou théoriquement
étaient les meilleurs du monde
on s'est aperçu que on était dépassé en
termes de droits qu'ils font pas soumis
au régime de la cda alexandre président
faure alexandre sur le plan économique
qui met des mesures protectionnistes
généralement mais alexandre baradez
peuvent la cresse ducobu vous êtes
d'accord sur la nécessité d'un état fort
d'une cohésion nationale et d'une techno
d'une technologie libéral il ya une
autre objection peut-être une dernière
réponse ni colloque faisait tout à
l'heure alexandre c'était de dire que
finalement les technocrates surdiplômés
de bruxelles ne faisait pas mieux que
les populistes que
vous stigmatisez dans votre chronique
alors enfin c'est tout à fait juste que
par exemple en matière qu'on a un énorme
rondin double retard qui est très
préoccupant en matière de vaccins et en
matière de plan de relance sur l'union
européenne
je la perds nos démocraties aussi non
mais j'avais simplement l'attention sur
le fait que à l'origine
l'union européenne elle n'a pas été fait
pour gérer les crises c'est là tout le
problème c'est qu'elle a été fait pour
faire de la norme et pour faire du
marché et créer du marché de la norme et
de la concurrence la gestion de crise
c'est tout autre chose c'est ce qu'on a
vu sur les vaccins ils ont passé des
mois à négocier des clauses pour essayer
d'avoir le meilleur prix et pour
partager les responsabilités alors que
le problème c'était d'accélérer et
d'avoir les vaccins en le plus vite
possible et dans le nombre le plus
important possible entre nous soit dit
c'est exactement le reproche qu'on avait
fait à madame bachelot il ya quelques
années pour acheter un énorme parce
qu'elle pour le coup elle avait joué
l'urgence est à un contretemps donc
derrière ceci c'est un problème qui se
pose aussi en matière de sécurité c'est
que si on veut faire gérer les crises à
l'union européenne
et là un domaine de compétence sur les
grands risques climatiques ou aux
trousses et plus intelligente d'être à
450 millions que d'être pays par pays
mais ça suppose de modifier la manière
de fonctionner de des institutions
européennes ça suppose d'avoir un autre
tempo on avait eu rappelez-vous le même
problème dans les balkans
quand c'était l'onu qui voulait piloter
et
les forces qui étaient déployés et
voulait certes dans n'ont fait qu'une
bouchée
parce qu' il fallait remonter jusqu'à
new york et redescendre pour savoir si
claude nadeau avec le avec maintenant
avec le kosovo et du tchèque s'est
rattrapé après non mais l'otan pour le
coup montré qu'ils savaient faire des
opérations alors on peut discuter de
savoir si elle était fondée ou pas mais
en tout cas leur relation était fait et
on va pas un débat sur le nom mais je
dirai tout simplement vous dire c'est
que fond c'était la démonstration le
temps avec ses qualités ses défauts mais
l'otan savait gérer et piloter des
opérations le nul ne savait pas le faire
aujourd'hui pour l'union européenne pour
un débat sur l'otan on est quand même
d'accord sur le fait que l'union
européenne ne s'est pas piloter gérer
alors je suis pas content nous n'aurons
une europe puissance mais pour l'instant
le constat c'est que ça reste une
chimère
je pense que laurent europe puissance
viendra de la puissance de ces
souveraineté des souverainetés
européenne à venir à l'assemblée
eh bien on continuera de suivre
justement cette évolution à l'évolution
de ce débat les prochaines semaines dans
les prochains jours le la grande
dépression de la démocratie c'est la
chronique de nicolas baverez carvalho et
nous dit d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
toujours d'accord avec les essais
chronique article de monsieur braises
mais son livre est très bon je ne sais
pas lequel
et auquel auquel fait référence car va
nouer mais on recommande les deux
derniers de nicolas baverez l'alertent
démocratique
et puis le monde selon tocqueville et on
recommande également recomposition
alexandre devait clos le nouveau monde
populiste et c'est aux éditions du cerf
allez y et très vite on se quitte je
retrouve dans un peu plus d'une heure et
demie pour audition publique l'invité ce
soit c'est patrick kanner et on se
retrouve pour point de vue demain même
heure même endroit à très vite sur
figaro live
[Musique]